nous sommes en direct depuis washington
où lé bella de l'université bardaine
chante pour le président des états unis
à l'occasion de son anniversaire
or elle n'a pas de culotte aux attaques
a découvert qu'elle tourne
le président a reçu un cadeau
d'anniversaire aux poils de la chanteuse
entre inquiète lé bella sont éliminés
pour l'instant vous est remplacé par les
champions d'europe
fra
nous sommes
comment on va rivaliser avec eux moi je
suis pas censé avoir d'idée je suis la
bombasse il me semble que c'est moi la
bombasse si on gagne les championnats du
monde
vous nous réintégrer chez vous gagnez
vous est minuscule
on va vous éclater votre équipe comment
le dire nul parmi les nuls la nullité
absolue mais au carré parce que 0 s'est
pas encore assez nul pour vous tout me
convient
vous devriez abandonné il ya votre
accent qui ressort c'est de
l'intimidation là on a gagné la seconde
guerre mondiale
quand j'évoque ray tout ça c'est pas de
la compétition que je me souviendrai
mais de vous le pendre de tordu
pareil pari pareil les meufs
on va pas avoir que des amis ils vont
nous regarder nous l'équipe américaine
et lire pourquoi la plus talentueuse
c'est une australienne ses fils ont fait
tomber une à une toutes les barrières
sur leur chemin
quel exemple motivant pour toutes ces
filles trop laide pour être des pom pom
girls